ilhan omar's latest anti-semitic blow-up
results in
zero serious blow back from democratic
leadership inflation is getting even
uglier and bipartisan populist agreement
breaks out to eat the rich i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
thousands of my listeners have already
secured their internet join them at
expressvpn.com
slash ben gets all the news in just one
moment but first this is indeed your
reminder that big tech
not on your side if they're not
interested in what is best for you
they're interested in monetizing you
and then using that money in order to
stifle your ability to actually
promulgate your own viewpoint
this is one of the reasons you need a
vpn that you trust
now i do the research on my sponsors i
only recommend brand smell listeners i
believe in i can say with full
confidence expressvpn is
the best vpn on the market a bunch of
reasons why number one
expressvpn does not log your internet
activity so a lot of these
free vpns will actually log your
internet activity and then sell them
which
defeats the exact purpose of what the
vpn is supposed to do number two
speed expressvpn uses lightweight a new
vpn protocol they engineered to make
user speeds faster than ever i've tried
a lot of vpns in the past
they can sometimes slow your connection
expressvpn is always blazing fast it
lets me stream videos in hd quality with
zero
buffering finally expressvpn is super
easy to use
you basically with a couple of clicks
you got it installed and you can just
use it protect yourself with the vpn i
use and trust use my link expressvpn.com
ben today get an extra three months for
free on a one year package that's
expressivevpn.com visit expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so
it was a week in which there were many
days ending and why
and because it was a week in which there
are many days ending and why one of
those days
undoubtedly would feature ilhan omar
saying something anti-semitic and or
anti-american because that's what elhan
omar does for a living the
representative from minnesota
is very often anti-american and her
rhetoric she is frequently anti-semitic
in her rhetoric
and she receives essentially zero
blowback from the democratic leadership
well things got awkward this week
because a few of the jewish democrats in
the house decided that they wanted to
put out some mild criticism of ilhan
omar after she tweeted out the following
here's what she tweeted quote
we must have the same level of
accountability and justice for all
victims of crimes against humanity
we have seen unthinkable atrocities
committed by the u.s
hamas israel afghanistan and the taliban
i asked secretary tony blinken where
people are supposed to go for justice so
this is her in a tweet equating
the united states hamas you know like a
terrorist group that has rockets behind
children
and that hides tunnels underneath
hospitals and under schools
and israel and the taliban you know one
of the most evil
groups on the planet a group of people
who literally try to murder young school
girls if they go to school
and so that is ilhan omar doing yeoman's
work on behalf
of terrorist rhetoric everywhere and
this is what she does i mean she's been
doing this her entire career she's been
doing this since she entered politics
and is a woman who once wrote a letter
to a judge recommending
less harsh jail time for a person trying
to join isis
because obviously american society was
so terrible and horrible that it drove
people
towards these sorts of activities i mean
elena is a disaster area she's been in
disaster area for a very long time
and yet every time she says one of these
things and she's said it over and over
right the jews are hypnotizing the world
or that it's all about the benjamins or
that
israel and hamas are exactly the same or
even worse that israel
is actually perpetuating terrorism you
know
when ilhan omar does this sort of stuff
the usual democratic response
is to simply whistle and walk away now
there's been a growing anti-semitism
problem inside the democratic party for
quite a while now
and this is perfectly obvious from the
fact that half the cbc half the
congressional black caucus
has met with louis farrakhan it's
perfectly obvious from the fact that aoc
met with radical anti-semite jeremy
corbyn and then tweeted it out and then
when she was caught
she said oh yeah i'll have a listening
session with members of the jewish
community never happen
right rashida talib openly associates
with people who are
complete abolitionists about the state
of israel would like to see israel wiped
from the map in fact
on a map in her office when she
originally took office she had a post-it
on the map that that where israel was
the posted said palestine and pointed an
arrow directly at israel which is a
genocidal point of view with regard
to the state of israel where she did it
to leave he didn't like the jews very
much
ilhan omar same sort of deal okay and
every time this sort of stuff comes up
the democratic party
edges right up to criticizing and then
they realize oh wait a second
these women they're they're muslim and
and they seem brown
and that means that if we criticize them
then we have violated our own
intersectional protocols
now this blew up into sort of ugly view
for the democrats yesterday
because a bunch of house democrats all
jewish put out a statement
quasi condemning ilhan omar it's just
kind of quasi edging up to it always
they edge up to it
now recognize something on the right
side of the aisle when marjorie taylor
greene was talking about jewish space
lasers every major republican came out
and said this is crazy and unacceptable
okay when when the when steve king
said stuff that was racist the entire
republican party stripped him
of his committees and then primaried him
inside the democratic party you can
hobnob with liz farrakhan you can hang
out with terror supporters like razia
oda you can hang out with linda sarsour
and do campaigning with her you can help
with jeremy corbyn you can say openly
and smeta crap
and the best they're going to do is
maybe they will mildly criticize now one
of the things that's really disturbing
about this particular criticism is that
it came only from the jewish members of
congress who are democrats
right and it was only 12 of them there
are 25 jewish democrats in congress
only 12 of them signed this joint
statement and it is really
really weak t but the fact that only
jews were willing to sign on to the
statement demonstrates that
anti-semitism is treated unlike any
other form of vicious hatred
inside the halls of democratic power if
somebody in the democratic party had
said something racist about ilhan omar
about her race do you imagine there
would only be
black members of congress who would say
something or it would be every member of
the democratic caucus that said
something but illidan omar
every couple of weeks she has to set
that just to set that calendar days
since anti-semitic accident back to zero
every couple of every couple of weeks
can only jews sign this statement there
wasn't a single
major democrat or minor democrat as far
as i'm aware who is not jewish
who even expressed sympathy for this
statement which is kind of incredible
basically they're saying if you're a
jewish democrat you are on your own
because
anti-semitism is not part of the
intersectional coalition jews are not
part of the intersectional coalition and
this has been true in progressive
circles for quite a while
you'll remember that just a few years
back there was something called the
chicago dyke march
which was an lgbt march in chicago and
they banned people from flying a flag
with the star of david on it
because jews are not part of the
intersectional coalition
blm has openly endorsed the
the terrorist activities of hamas and
the gaza strip i know that we're
supposed to pretend
that they were just supporting quote
unquote the palestinians but they
weren't
okay they have openly acknowledged that
they wish to see israel disappear
blm i mean this was in their original
manifesto
they talk about liberating palestine
which really does mean
getting rid of israel from the from the
river to the sea and when they say they
support the quote-unquote palestinians
in the middle of a hamas
gaza versus israel rocket war it's
pretty obvious what they are talking
about they're really not trying to hide
the ball very hard here
plus if you go to any of these blm
rallies they'll actually have like full
anti-semitic signs up there
so the intersectional coalition does not
welcome jews and so the jews in the
democratic party
are on their own right here so here was
the statement they put out about ilhan
omar equating
israel and hamas which by the way again
is only part of what she said she also
equated the united states in the taliban
which is again typical ilhan omar she's
consistently suggesting the united
states is a massive human rights
violator akin to terrorist groups
because this is what she does and then
of course she laughs about 9 11 on
occasion
she's really a wonder and a joy amazing
that we have such great congress people
in the united states
she tweeted out equating the united
states and israel to hamas in the
taliban
is as offensive as it is misguided this
is this is what the the jewish democrats
put out
ignoring the differences between
democracies governed by the rule of law
and contemptible organizations that
engage in terrorism at best discredits
one's intended argument and at worst
reflects deep-seated prejudice
the and like united st at times
deserving of critique but false
equivalencies give cover to terrorist
groups
we urge congresswoman omar to clarify
her words placing the us and israel in
the same category as hamas
and the taliban clarify right so they
didn't they didn't condemn her they
didn't just say this is gross they could
have ended this
before the last sentence right they
didn't instead they said we'll give you
a way out just clarify and we will
pretend you didn't mean what you very
obviously meant since you said it over
and over and over
all you have to do is clarify just a
little bit
so here is how ilhan omar originally
clarified
she originally clarified by accusing
the democrats in her own party of
islamaphobia
because this is what she is right she is
a person who is viciously anti-semitic
and if you criticize her
then she claims that you are anti-muslim
in some way
no i'm just against people who aren't
anti-semitic actually as it turns out
there are many muslims who are not
eleanor is not one of them
there are many muslims who are very
pro-america ilhan omar and her rhetoric
certainly is not
and we're allowed to criticize johan
omar without it being quote-unquote
islamophobic
but this is the you want to know why in
the wake of all of these
acts of jew hatred that we saw on the
streets of new york and miami and los
angeles and chicago
in the last few weeks in the wake of
that all the democrats were tweeting out
about islamophobia
because what ilhan omar and rashida
taliban company and the intersectional
coalition have succeeded in doing
is they have succeeded in suggesting
that if you call out anti-semitism
this is an act of islamophobia which by
the way is slanderous towards muslims
because it turns out that muslims don't
actually have to be anti-semitic
if the claim is that you calling out
anti-semitism is inherently islamophobic
what you are actually saying is that
islam is anti-semitic
which again there are many many many
millions of muslims who are not
anti-semitic
in any case here's ilhan omar she
tweeted out right this is her
clarification
original clarification she tweeted out
it's shameful for colleagues who call me
when they need my support to now put out
a statement asking for clarification
and not just call the islamophobic
tropes in this statement are offensive
what are these islamophobic tropes
seriously where can she name them
notice notice the game she's playing
right here so the
anti-semitic tropes she's used in the
past included the jews hypnotized the
world and that jewish money controls
american congress
and those are actual anti-semitic tropes
there's not a single islamophobic trope
in that entire statement but she's
accusing her colleagues of islamophobia
the constant harassment
and silencing from the signers of this
letter is unbearable unbearable oh
oh the tears take lebron james flopping
politically like oh my god oh
i get oh i can't believe it the constant
harassment oh it's so difficult to be on
omar it's so difficult
to be elected to congress being an
immigrant to the united states and being
on the cover of rolling stone and being
featured
on the foreign affairs committee despite
being openly anti-jewish well i mean
what what a
rough world she has by the way this lie
that her colleagues never go to her
quietly
it is just that it is a lie okay the
fact is
members of the jewish minneapolis
community went to her quietly they went
behind closed doors and then she
betrayed them
by talking about how terrible they were
basically publicly rashida talib has
done the same thing so is aoc
amazing to watch democrats like gilhan
omar who has not been shy
about ripping into other democrats
suggests that it's the responsibility of
other democrats to come to her
and clarify with her quietly about all
this just such a lie they don't do
anything okay so
what has been the response from the
higher-ups in the democratic party
because it looked like it was coming to
a head it looked as though
finally it was going to be the jewish
democrats versus
ilhan omar and the rest of the squad
because you had people like rashida
talib
tweeting in defense of ilhan alma right
rashida to leave tweeted this out this
is such
unbelievable gaslighting quote freedom
of speech doesn't exist for muslim women
in congress
she said on twitter to her millions of
followers
as printed in every major newspaper
freedom of speech doesn't exist
for muslim women in congress really
really you wanna know our freedom of
speech doesn't exist for muslim women
pretty much everywhere in the islamic
world that's why freedom of speech
doesn't exist for muslim women
women like doesn't exist this statement
is so self-contradictory it's
unbelievable
doesn't exist for muslim women in
congress
i think we've established that muslim
women have freedom of speech
in the united states they're in congress
the legislature what in the actual
but you're silencing rashida how dare
you silence for she doesn't sound
so silent but you know
maybe that's just me because i'm
actually reading her words freedom of
speech doesn't exist for muslim women in
congress the benefit of the doubt
doesn't exist for muslim women in
congress
there's no benefit of the doubt she
literally equated the united states and
the taliban in israel and hamas and she
does this
over and over and over you don't get the
benefit of the doubt the ninth time
you get the benefit of the doubt like
the first time maybe the second time
by the time you're getting to like six
seven eight nine anti-semitic statements
people start to go hey
maybe we shouldn't give this person the
benefit of the doubt
weird you know i gave you the benefit of
the doubt the first time my wallet just
appeared at your house but like the
eighth time my wallet disappeared at
your house i had to start thinking to
myself hey maybe there's something going
on at this person's apartment says
recited to lead house democratic
leadership should be ashamed
of its relentless exclusive tone
policing of congresswomen of color
notice that the turnabout is fair play
here right how dare nancy pelosi how
dare anybody
criticize muslim women of color you
can't do that you can't do that
relentless tone again these are the same
people who are claiming
that those that jewish democratic
statement which was like the mildest
thing i've ever seen
that that is tone policing that they're
censoring them okay so finally
you have people like i mean lcd did the
same thing by the way here is aoc's
response
pretty sick and tired of the constant
vilification like intentional
mischaracterization and public targeting
of vilhan omar coming from our caucus
they have no concept for the danger they
put her in by like skipping private
conversations and leaping to fueling
targeted news cycles around her this is
coming from the same lady
who every day goes out and rips on joe
manchin and basically suggests he's a
racist but
i love this that ilhan omar oh man
they're constantly vilified oh she's
such a victim ilhanover so is aoc
they're such victims
the cry bullying is beyond compare i
mean truly crazy
aoc on the cover of rolling stone with
ilhan omar
and nancy pelosi oh my god people are
just targeting her oh the vilification
oh woe is me america's a terrible place
people
people notice that ilhanomar hates jews
and then they said it
they noticed that she equated the united
states and the taliban and then they
pointed that out
oh the viciousness oh the cruelty
but here's the bottom line this is ilhan
omar's party and she can cry if she
wants to
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about
a simple fact you really need life
insurance okay if you are a responsible
human being
you need life insurance the reason that
you need life insurance is because god
forbid something happens to you you need
to make sure your family doesn't just
lose you
and and they don't lose your stream of
income right you got to make sure
that your family has a pot to
you know in in any case this is why you
need life insurance and this is why you
need policy genius because policy genius
makes it easy to compare quotes from
over a dozen top
insurers all in one place why compare
you could say 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius in fact you
could save 1300 bucks or more per year
on life insurance by using policy genius
to compare policies
the licensed experts at policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius an excellent rating on trustpilot
getting started super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
in minutes you can work out how much
life
insurance coverage you need and compare
personalized quotes to find your best
price
when you're ready to apply the policy
genius team will handle the paperwork
and the scheduling for free policy
genius never sells your information
to other companies and they're not going
to add on any extra fees so what exactly
are you waiting for head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro get started right now policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important
to get it right okay then finally after
all of this after all this hubbub she
issued a clarification
elena martin uh a clarification she
released the following clarification on
her questions during the house foreign
affairs committee
this week quote on monday i asked
secretary of state anthony blinken about
an ongoing international criminal court
investigations
okay not good grammar to be clear the
conversation was about accountability
for specific incidents regarding these
icc cases
not a moral comparison between hamas and
the taliban and the us and israel
i was in no way equating terrorist
organizations with democratic countries
with well-established judicial systems
well number one thanks to ohan omar for
acknowledging that israel is a
democratic country with a
well-established judicial system
that said that's a first for ilhan omar
but also can we go back to her original
tweet
because according to her she's not
making a comparison quote
we have seen unthinkable atrocities
committed by the us hamas
israel afghanistan and the taliban
i kind of think you were making the
comparison i kind of think you were
cause you do it all
the damn time okay so she issues her
clarification and now the democratic
party has its way out
now they can all pretend that she didn't
mean what she very clearly meant
right now they can all go go back to go
back everything weapons down
everything is fine so if john garamendi
democratic representation i don't think
that ilhan omar intended to compare
the united states and israel to hamas
and the taliban even though she doesn't
like all the damn time
no no she no ill han no
come on i think she needs to be much
more careful
i don't think she ever intended to lump
the united states and
israel into the same terrorism that was
being conducted by those other
organizations
terrorist organizations uh she had a
she ought to walk it back she ought to
be very very careful here the problem is
that this kind of language
incites violence here in the united
states okay but you didn't mean it guys
probably
probably she didn't mean it now do you
think that that benefit of the doubt
would accrue to
any other members of congress other than
reputed to liberal hanuman
truly do you think that nope so here is
nancy pelosi's statement so here's
an amazing thing there's a several hour
period here where ilhan omar had not
quote unquote walked anything back or
clarified
right there was a several hour period
yesterday when these jewish democrats
had put out a statement and ilhan omar
and her crew
were busily tweeting about how vicious
and terrible these jewish democrats were
not a single member of the media hunted
down a single democrat in the house
and asked who do you side with here who
do you think is right
not a single one not a single one went
to nancy pelosi and said do you have any
response
to these jewish democrats claiming that
illinois is engaged in basically
anti-semitism it's amazing
so if marjorie taylor green before she
enters congress puts out a weird
facebook post
about jewish space lasers or whatever
and by the way if even if i did control
a jewish space laser i wouldn't tell you
guys
but when they went to every single
republican in congress and asked about
marjorie taylor green she's a
backbencher ellen omar is on the foreign
affairs committee
illinois is appearing on the cover of
magazines with the democratic house
leadership
okay not a single question i am aware of
to any member of congress
about this sort of stuff until after
ellen omar had already performed her
walk back it's certainly no
no questions to the members of the house
leadership right the media just fell
asleep at the switch or they don't
really care
and the answer is they don't really care
because they are too invested in the
same intersectional
politics that the democrats are invested
in which means the radicals rule the
roost here there are two ways radicals
take over the democratic party one is
they get elected to congress
that's happening sometimes but not all
the time the second is the rest of the
party simply caves to the radicals
because the radicals are loud and
annoying and irritating
and that is definitely happening so here
is here was a statement
from speaker nancy pelosi majority
leader hoyer majority whip clyburn
assistant speaker catherine clark caucus
chairman hakeem jeffries caucus vice
chair pete aguilar
quote legitimate criticism of the
policies of both the united states and
israel is protected by the values of
free speech and democratic debate
and indeed such criticism is essential
to the strength and health of our
democracies
but drawing false equivalencies between
democracies like the us and israel and
groups that engage in terrorism like
hamas and the taliban
foments prejudice and undermines
progress toward a future of peace and
security for all
we welcome the clarification by
congresswoman omar there is no moral
equivalency between the us and israel
and hamas and the taliban oh well you
welcomed it did you
wow yeah i mean amazing so you called
for the jewish democrats called for a
clarification
she clarified by basically saying you
know that thing i said
you just misinterpreted it i definitely
didn't mean that thing that i very
obviously said
and pelosi
incredible so she'll just continue
getting away with this sort of stuff and
we'll play this game every couple of
months
and the democratic party will continue
to engage with the growing anti-semitism
in its own ranks and pretend that it
doesn't exist
the new york times obviously is going to
foment this stuff here's how the new
york times reported this you ready
because the new york times has seth
mandel points out he's over at the
washington examiner
he says the new york times is not a
newspaper correct here's what the here's
how the new york times covered this you
ready
republicans eager to stoke outrage and
portray democrats as anti-israel
jump on miss omar's language especially
after anti-semitic comments by one of
their own members
representative marjorie taylor green of
georgia whose recent comparisons
of the holocaust to pandemic safety
policies drew condemnation from her own
leaders
wait what the f what does this have to
do exactly with republicans
it's always republicans pounds ilhan
omar anti-semite shooter to lead
anti-semite democratic caucus
mildly condemns them and then backs away
and the story is republicans pounds also
how exactly is that an owning of the
republicans i'm confused so according to
the new york times the bad guys here are
somehow the republicans who condemned
anti-semitism in their own ranks and
also condemned among democrats
meanwhile the democrats who refuse to
condemn anti-semitism in their own ranks
they're they're totally fine that is a
hot take right there
but again this democratic party it is
run by the radicals
on all of the important issues they
kowtow to the radicals
and these issues of shifting the overton
window
to completely include open anti-semitism
is pretty and anti-americanism by the
way i should point out again that
statement is rather anti-american
comparing the united states
and our and our armed forces to the
taliban and hamas
but apparently all of that is totally
fine it's totally fine because ilhan
omar is part of the intersectional
coalition
and you are not end of story that is all
that matters to the democratic party
at this point so they will march arm and
arm forward
so long as those people believe in all
of these same progressive policies
that they believe in allies of
convenience are more important than
fundamental principles about
you know being anti-hate and all that
already in just a second we'll get to
the latest economic reports
it turns out that blowing money into the
economy at extraordinary rates
and encouraging people never to go to
work again it creates this thing it's
called inflation i know you've heard of
it we'll get to that in just one second
first
if you've been listening to the show for
a while you've probably heard me talk
about my helix sleep mattress so
my kids keep me up at all times of night
but that means that in the moments those
brief
respites between my children waking me
up i need to be on a mattress made for
me which is why i love my helix sleep
mattress well here's the thing
helix isn't just mattresses anymore
they've now gone beyond the bedroom
and they've started making sofas they
just launched a new company called all
form they're making premium customizable
sofas and chairs
shipped directly to your door these all
form sofas they are awesome they are
made just for you it's the easiest way
you can customize the sofa using premium
materials
at a fraction of the cost of traditional
stores you can pick your fabric it is
spill stain scratch resistant the sofa
color the color of the legs sofa size
and shape make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
they've got arm chairs love seats all
the way up to an eight-seat sectional
there's something for everyone
you can always start small and buy more
seats later on if you want your all-form
sofa to grow and change with you
when you move all form sofas are also
delivered directly to your door
in the past if you wanted to order a
sofa you need to hire somebody to come
and assemble it in your home or
break your back trying to put it
together yourself all form has a simple
quick assembly
no tools needed i've got that all from
sofa i've got the three seat sofa with
the chase in the sand color with
espresso legs and this thing is durable
as all get out which is great because my
kids ruin everything if getting a sofa
without trying to store sounds risky
good news you get 100 days to decide if
you even want to keep it that's more
than three months if you don't love it
they'll pick it up for free
give you a full refund also they have a
forever warranty literally forever so
you got nothing to lose
check them out right now allform.com and
right now they'll give you 20
off all orders at allform.com that's all
form dot com
slash ben okay meanwhile biodynamics is
a complete failure
cbs news reported yesterday that
inflation has now reached a 13-year high
prices are rising as the u.s economy
recovers from the pandemic downturn
the inflation rate soared to a 13-year
high in may
pushing the cost of living five percent
higher than this time
last year labor department data shows
the consumer price index rose
.6 from april exceeding expectations
record high prices for used cars were
the largest contributor to the inflation
surge
with prices climbing more than seven
percent the nation's inflation
watchdog the federal reserve is
dismissing concerns over rising prices
saying it's only temporary okay well it
may only be temporary but the question
is how long does temporary remain
temporary
is there are two problems with regards
to the biodynamics policy one
is the short-term inflation the fed
keeps saying that inflation is going to
go down at some point here now
the experts were saying earlier this
year that the inflation rate for the
entire year
of 2021 was going to be like 2.6 percent
we're already at like four percent
so unless things dramatically decrease
in the remaining half of the year
we've got a problem on our hands right
it's very easy to fall into an
inflationary cycle so long as you keep
pumping money into the economy as long
as congress keeps passing unemployment
benefits so
long as congress keeps pushing for these
two trillion dollar infrastructure
packages
keep pouring money into an economy while
encouraging people never to go back to
work the definition of inflation is too
many dollars
chasing too little product you end up
with price inflation and this means that
your dollar doesn't go
as far it means that people are unlikely
to invest as much in american debt
which again drives the the fed to start
purchasing sub more of the debt to
inject more money into the economy
all of this is really bad so that is
problem number one problem number two is
that the general
view of the bidenomics crew is that the
more money you suck
out of the private sector and
redistribute in these ways the better it
is
the problem with this of course is that
it leads to economic stagnation
because it turns out the people who are
most likely to invest the people who are
most likely
to put their money in r d to develop new
products and services
are the people whose money you are
taking away from them right the truth is
every check that you have ever gotten as
an employee is coming from somebody who
is richer than you
right that is just a a general good rule
of thumb
and that will always continue to be true
because you generally don't have
people who are poor engaging or
employing people who are richer
people who are richer because they have
more capital they tend to then expend
that capital to take risks and build
businesses right
entrepreneurship drives the economy
forward the reason
that the economy now is more robust than
the economy 50 years ago and it is
is because of all the new products and
services human nature hasn't changed
what has changed is the cool stuff that
you can get for a buck that you could
not get for a buck
50 years ago the truth is the middle
income person in the united states today
is living better than the richest person
on earth was probably in 1900
i mean undoubtedly in 1900 they didn't
have working toilets in many places in
the world in 1900.
like there were no cell phones there
were no cars right
like devices have gotten better things
have gotten better the reason things
have gotten better is because people
took their money and they invested it in
brand new products and services that you
enjoy
the entire bidenomics model is designed
to take money away from those people
and then redistribute it as geniuses
like joe biden think is fit
we need to have ronald clayne deciding
where where dollars go all these people
who have never created a product have
never created
a services have never employed a person
with their own money all of these people
are saying they know what to do with the
money better than the people who've
actually
you know hired hundreds of millions of
people
which is kind of an incredible statement
and what are they doing what are the
experts con
doing right now well they're busy
blowing out the inflation rates the same
people who are inflating the currency
are the people who say that we should
give them more money
and and they should borrow more money in
order to presumably remake the economy
quote unquote better now right now
there are 9 million open jobs in the
united states 9 million
there are only 3.5 million jobs gained
during the last few months
what does that mean it means people are
staying home they are not re-entering
the workforce
biden and team they keep suggesting the
reason for this is people are wary of
covet well if they are that's because
you guys suck at pr
if the reality is that everyone has had
a chance to get the vaccine now
and in most states the vast majority of
the elderly have already had the vaccine
which means once you've had a chance to
get the vaccine whether you get it
whether you don't get it that one's on
you
okay so it is not covet hesitancy that
is driving down employment rates i was
talking to a construction guy
here yesterday in florida and he was
telling me he literally cannot find
laborers people do not want to come to
work
simultaneously he's telling me that the
price on all goods
has gone up tremendously he can't get
lumber he's had to do roofing
in different ways he can't use foam for
roofing because the materials are just
not available
because again production is not ramping
up to meet the price inflation that is
occurring
according to the washington post prices
rose by five percent in may compared
with a year ago
the largest increase since the great
recession continuing a steady climate
inflation even as policymakers insist on
staying the course
price spikes often coincide with
downturns officials from the white house
and federal reserve have predicted that
prices will climb over the coming months
especially compared with a year ago when
the economy was reeling from coveted
pandemic shutdowns however
the move adds new fuel to criticism from
republicans and at least one prominent
liberal economist that too much
government spending could wreak havoc
and lead to an overheated economy
according to the washington post it
could take months before it's clear
whether the current rise in inflation is
temporary but the steady climb is
already weighing on numerous policy
debates republicans pushed back hard on
president biden's proposal to spend 4
trillion
on infrastructure and other proposals
complaining it amounted to an infusion
of too much money at a time when prices
on certain products were rising faster
than wages
on certain products on most products gop
opposition has led the white house to
rethink its spending strategy in recent
weeks
most recent inflation figures do not
seem to have forced any course
correction decisions inside the biden
administration or at the fed
both predict prices will continue to
rise until supply chains and consumer
demand recalibrate and the economy
recovers
the fed says it's not going to rush to
raise interest rates so what is this
resulting in it's resulting
in businesses taking out cheap debt and
then using it
on hard assets if you don't like
businesses doing that perhaps you should
be protesting you know the governmental
doctors who are actually answerable to
us
right as we'll see people instead have
this sort of simplistic view of
economics in which you rip on
corporations for doing exactly what
corporations do but the reality is you
need to change the incentive structures
if you wish for the corporations to
change
their order of business okay we'll get
to that in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you've
got a medical issue that could be solved
easily and quickly from the comfort of
your own home why would you not go and
take advantage of it right now with
erectile dysfunction it can be
embarrassing to go in have an
appointment talk about it
instead why not just use roman with
roman you get a free online evaluation
and ongoing care for ed
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home a us licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships you free with two
day shipping
the whole process is straightforward and
discreet getting started is super simple
you just go to getroman.com complete an
online visit today
take care of your ed without leaving
your home complete an online visit today
connect with a healthcare professional
and get that problem taken care of again
a lot of health problems people tend to
kind of just brush them off oh well you
know maybe it'll go away on its own
pretty rare that something like ed goes
away on its own instead you may need a
doctor to help you out and why not do it
quickly and easily and inexpensively at
getroman.com right now
you get 15 bucks off your first month
when you use that web address get
roman.com
ben it's time to take care of that id
and remember get started today you'll
save 15 bucks on your very first order
of ed treatment with getroman.com ben
alrighty it is that glorious time of the
week when i give a shout out to a daily
ware member today
is jose garza on instagram who
understands proper hydration
when attaining your fitness goals in
this pic jose is sitting at his kitchen
counter preparing to wash down a sub
sandwich with delicious tears from the
world's most elite beverage vessel the
caption reads
post workout just about to watch ben
shapiro real daily wire new episode
by the way far superior to my wife's
louder with crowder mug hashtag
leftist tears tumblr yes jose that
crowder ashtray can do nothing for the
gains you are seeking you've made the
right call
well done my friend thanks for the pick
thanks for being a daily wire member
also it is no secret that the amount of
content we are putting out is growing
rapidly both in quantity and in quality
from our new investigative journalism
team to our sports column
to my own fact-filled podcast there is
so much to see and hear and read and
enjoy
even the most avid daily where i
remember would be hard pressed to keep
up don't worry
we thought of everything and we have a
solution for you you can now find all
the conservative content you love and
you need wherever you are all
on that daily wire app even if you're
not a daily wire subscriber you will be
the first to know what's trending with
mobile notifications for the latest news
and all your favorite content only a
touch away
so download that daily wire app stay up
to speed with the freshest conservative
voices around no matter
where you are also i'd like to take a
moment just to acknowledge all the
people that make all the new projects
and growth at the daily wear possible
you our audience now as i'm sure you
know we have seen a ton of change in
growth in the last several months
we've been doing a ton of stuff i'm
genuinely excited about all the cool
stuff that we are going to be announcing
in coming months but we got to thank you
for making it possible now as i say
every day on the show i talk about a lot
of amazing products and services from
sponsors i personally use
and personally enjoy but we want to get
to know you better so we can actually
choose our sponsors with you and mine
and tailor our sponsors to you
we've been running a survey for a couple
weeks now to get to know our audience
members better if you haven't already
taken it it is not too late go to
dailywire.com
shapiro fill out my audience survey tell
us a little more about yourself and to
sweeten the deal
everyone who completes the survey will
be entered to win a 1 000
gift card you can only take the survey
once per daily wire show so if you want
to increase your chances of winning
a thousand bucks go listen to michael
knowles andrew claven or matt walsh get
access to their surveys as well again
my survey link is dailywire.com shapiro
we would love to hear from you you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
well all of this bad spending policy is
leading to some pretty
dire economic warnings from deutsche
bank according to the hill as the world
economy awakens from the 15-month
slumber cause by the pandemic deutsche
bank has launched a series of research
articles to spark debate and discussion
about pressing post-pandemic economic
issues on june 7. deutsche bank issued
its first report of the new series
titled
inflation the defining macro story of
this decade according to the report
quote
u.s macro policy macroeconomic policy
and indeed the very role of the
government in the economy is undergoing
its biggest shift in direction in 40
years
in turn we are concerned it will bring
about uncomfortable levels of inflation
based on the latest inflation report
from the united states the u.s bureau of
labor statistics points out that in
april the consumer price index for all
urban consumers rose
0.8 on a seasonally adjusted basis
rising 4.2 percent
over the last 12 months deutsche bank
knows the current fiscal stimulus is
more comparable with that scene around
world war
ii then u.s deficits remain between 15
to 30 for four years
while there are many significant
differences between the pandemic and
world war ii we would note that annual
annual inflation during that period was
8.4 percent 14.6
and 7.7 percent in 46 47 and 48
after the economy normalized and pent-up
demand was released
apparently there are a couple of big
problems according to deutsche bank one
is
the giant spending by congress they say
monetary stimulus has been equally
breathtaking
in numerical terms the fed's balance
sheet has almost doubled during the
pandemic to nearly eight trillion
dollars during the 2008 crisis it only
increased a little more than one
trillion dollars and then another two
trillion in the subsequent six years
so basically this is just the federal
reserve creating fake money and then
buying up bonds to inject it into the
capital markets
the deutsche bank report says we worry
inflation will make a comeback few still
remember how our societies and economies
were threatened by high inflation 50
years ago
the most basic law of economics the ones
that have stood the test of time over
the millennium
have not been suspended an explosive
growth in debt financed largely by
central banks is likely to lead to
higher inflation raising prices will
touch everyone the effects could be
devastating particularly for the most
vulnerable in society
okay so that's deutsche bank warning
about what is happening right now and
indeed the united states
is setting setting records for taxes
spending and deficits through may
according to cns news
federal taxes hit a record 2.6 trillion
dollars federal spending climbed to 4.6
trillion dollars is october through may
resulting in a federal deficit of two
trillion dollars that's just october
through may okay which is just an
astonishing
increase in the federal deficit over the
course of essentially half a year
that is wild stuff okay now the
predictable result of all of this
is not just inflation it's also as i say
economic stagnation because
when you remove money from the private
sector and when you blow out the debt
and must blow out the value of savings
what you end up doing
is making it more difficult for
businesses to do anything
because again there are two problems one
is the inflation problem and the second
is what happens if the federal
government
can the federal reserve continues to
pump money into the banks by issuing
overnight rates that are zero or below
zero which encourages banks to lend
and what if businesses look around they
go wait a second there's no there's no
demand why are we borrowing
why exactly should i leverage up when
the demand is not keeping up
with my leverage why would i borrow
money i'm not going to be able to pay
back
it doesn't make any sense and so we are
seeing both of these things come to pass
there's a reason that joe biden's budget
his six trillion dollar garbage budget
that he's pushing there's a reason
that it forecasts a two percent rate of
growth for the next ten years every year
and that is high it will end up being
below two percent if joe biden gets his
way
in terms of this economy simultaneously
you're seeing people get ticked off at
corporations
for doing what exactly it is that they
do which is they see
a cheap debt instrument available to
them and they immediately start taking
out loans and then buying up hard assets
now there are people get angry at the
corporations for this you're getting
angry at the wrong people
i may not like it either but the point
that the point is
that unless you stop the federal reserve
from pumping money into the system
corporations are going to take cheap
loans and then they're going to use
those loans to arbitrage they're going
to take the loans
at zero percent and then they're gonna
lend it out of three percent or they're
gonna go buy hard assets they think are
going to appreciate at three percent or
more over the course of the next 50
years
this is leading to massive price
inflation
especially in real estate so there's a
big story that came out yesterday and a
lot of people write left and center
really mad about it and this is where
populists
go wrong not because they are wrong in
being angry about things but because
very often they are they're angry at the
wrong people it is not a corporation's
fault
if cheap loans are available they are
taking the cheap loans and then going
and buying real estate
anymore then it would be their fault if
cheap loans are available and they go
and they take the cheap loans and then
they buy stock
okay it is the thought this all comes
down to government policy
if you are willing to take up the risk
of buying an asset
at an at a higher price than the market
would suggest
if you're willing to put that risk
that's your problem so long as you don't
get bailed out so there are two things
that people who are seriously troubled
by what's going on economically
ought to oppose with all of their heart
and might okay one is the inflationary
policy of the federal reserve
the cheap debt that continues to be
pumped into the economy
the government spending that continues
to promote
unemployment and keep people at home
that is one and two
no bailouts no bailouts if a big
corporation like blackrock decides to
take out a bunch of money
from a bank or they they decide they're
going to sell their bonds to the federal
reserve and they're going to get back
all of this cheap money and then they
take that cheap money and they invested
in real estate
and then the real estate go south no
bailouts
and the moral hazard of tarp was just
that it created a massive moral hazard
and just like occupy wall street was
angry at the wrong people they were over
they should have been occupying wall
street they should have been occupying k
street
they should have been over there in
washington dc yelling at congress
you remember the occupy wall street
movement that cropped up in 2010
in the aftermath of the of the great
bubble bursting in the great recession
you recall people went over to wall
street and started yelling at wall
street and i was like why are you
yelling at wall street you should be
yelling at congress
it's congress is answerable to you do
you think yelling at blackrock is gonna
make them stop pursuing
fiscally smart decisions it's not going
to
the reason they're doing what they're
doing is the incentive structure is all
screwed up
go yell at your congress person go yell
at the federal reserve go yell at joe
biden
those are the people you elected those
are the people who are answerable to you
not the people who work at blackrock and
yet people are misdirecting all of their
energies they're mad at corporations
because
again what populism does is it it very
often gets the diagnosis correct
but then the actual prescription is
completely wrong so the diagnosis
is right that you don't want
corporations giant corporations
necessarily
coming in and buying up swathes of real
estate and preventing first-time
homeowners from being able to buy at
market prices you don't want them
artificially driving up the price of
real estate but this is the point
it's not an artificial drive up of the
price of real estate unless there's
artificially cheap money
being pushed into the system the price
of a house
is what somebody is willing to pay for
it so you can say
that blackrock or these other big
corporations are paying above market
prices
yes they're paying above what the market
price was before they're willing to pay
for it now what they are willing to pay
for it is the new market price
if you don't like that market price
perhaps you should oppose the federal
reserve's inflationary policy
which again that's a government agency
blackrock is just taking out debt and
then they're spending it and you should
also have to explain by the way
why it is that you think that the
current homeowner shouldn't have the
right to sell to blackrock
at an inflated price that homeowner is
you know part of the consenting bargain
here
hey yes there is there's an affected
third party that affected third party
shouldn't be angry at blackrock that
affected dirty party should be angry
that the fed keeps giving out cheap
money
and yet people are directing their anger
at all the wrong places there's a piece
in the wall street journal about this
that drove
all sorts of ire the other day that if
you sell a house these days the buyer
might be a pension fund
now again if the buyer is a pension fund
you know who owns
stock in pension funds a lot of people
who are not actually big corporations
a lot of unions on stock and pension
funds a lot of retirees
a lot of your 401k is tied up in those
pension funds
this is sort of like when people got
very mad at the short sellers for no
apparent reason with regard to gamestop
like oh those short sellers they're so
bad look at them they're they're
leveraging up to short sell
gamestop and that's just terrible or
maybe they are pricing in
the risk of a market correction with
regard to gamestop right that's
literally what short sellers do they are
necessary to the market
in order to properly price all of these
assets and so
you can think that it's kind of
hilarious what happened to the short
sellers with regard to gamestop but you
can also recognize that short sellers
are not
malevolent forces in the financial
universe any more than people who pump
up the price of a stock
are malevolent forces as long as you
bear the risk of your own decisions
it's on you what happens next in any
case
this wall street journal article says a
bidding war broke out this winter at a
new subdivision north of houston the
prize this time was the entire
subdivision
not just a single suburban house
illustrating the rise of big investors
as a potent new force
in the us housing market dr horton built
124 houses in conroe texas rented them
out and then put the whole community
amber pines at foster's ridge on the
block now who's whose of investors and
home rental firms flocked to the
december sale the winning 32 million
bid came from an online property
investing platform fundrise llc
which manages more than one billion
dollars on behalf of about 150 000
individuals
the country's most prolific home builder
booked roughly twice what it typically
makes selling houses to middle class
and encouraging debut in the business of
selling entire neighborhoods to
investors
we wouldn't expect every single family
community we sell to sell at a 50
gross margin said the builder's finance
chief bill wheat
from individuals with smartphones and a
few thousand bucks to pensions and
private equity firms of billions
yields chasing investors are snapping up
single-family houses to rent out or flip
they're competing for houses with
ordinary americans who are armed with
the cheapest mortgage financing ever and
driving up home prices
again cheap fiscal policy means
inflation
and whether it is people creating a
bubble thanks to subprime mortgages
in 2006 or whether it is the federal
government pursuing inflationary
monetary policy that drives down the
price of loans and therefore
drives up the price of things like real
estate centralized
bureaucratic money decision making is
generally not a good idea with regard to
this stuff
and there are many people on the left
who make fun of people who call for a
gold standard the reason for gold
standard is specifically so you can't do
the scrap
the reason for gold standard is that you
don't have people manipulating
the worth of money this is why when
you wonder why so many members of the
left are pissed off at bitcoin the
reason that people are pissed off at
bitcoin is because bitcoin is not
controllable by a central authority
which is why people like me tend to be
fans of bitcoin at least in theory
but people instead yesterday got super
mad if you pointed out
that the ir was misplaced that if you're
mad at blackrock maybe you should be mad
at blackrock maybe you should actually
be mad at the federal government
people like no i want to be mad at
blackrock
hey and it's the same sort of ire that
is driving all of the rage
with regard to this new propublica
report so amazingly enough propublica
you know they got a hold of a bunch of
leaked irs documents now quick note
kind of hilarious that the entire media
put the kibosh
on quote-unquote leaked documents from
hunter biden's computer right because
they were leaked is what we were told by
the social media
bros then obviously leaked documents
from the irs which is a crime
right obviously leaked documents were
printed by pro publica
and they've been blasted all over social
media so i i don't think the hundred
biden shutdown had anything to do
with leaked documents in any case you
know what those leaked documents showed
pretty much nothing
what they showed is that wealth is not
taxed the same way as income which again
makes sense because wealth that has
never been cashed out is not
in fact income if you have a house
and over the course of 10 years your
house doubles in value you are not
worth more money on a practical
day-to-day level unless you sell the
house or take out debt
take a second mortgage or something
right the reality is that until you
realize the value
of the increased value nothing has
changed for you it shouldn't be taxed
the same way
how would you even do that okay and yet
people are super pissed they
they just they don't understand this
they look at jeff bezos they see that
jeff bezos is really rich and because
they see jeff bezos
is really rich like that guy should pay
more taxes and this sort of populist ire
it does span both sides there's a
populist movement on the right that
embraces just this sort of stuff
and there's a populist movement on the
left it's sort of bernie sanders
progressives who believe this sort of
stuff and they sort of
horseshoe around you'll see that there
are populists on the right who do the
same sort of class baiting that people
on the left do
how is it that jeff bezos paid no tax in
2000 well because he didn't realize
income in 2018.
the value of his stock went up but he
didn't sell any of his stock if the
value of the stock went down would you
give him a tax refund
i don't think so and yet still this has
been treated as a major story by the
media
again that pro-publica story as daily
wire points out found that billionaires
often manage to employ tax loopholes to
legally avoid paying income tax except
those aren't
tax loopholes right those are just how
taxes work
and the highest earning americans
overall pay the lion's share of u.s
income taxes period the bottom half of
income earners pay less than three
percent
of all income taxes plus people who are
wealthy pay sales tax on their purchases
income is not the same as wealth the
bottom line though is that the ire at
corporations
is ir that is being misplaced it is
being put in the wrong place
now there's area corporations that i
think is sometimes being put in the
right place but again
here's the rule with corporations you
need to change the incentive structure
corporations respond to incentives
corporations are just
legal mechanisms for developing profit
that is all corporations are
and for limiting liability that's all
they are they respond
to incentive structures so if you don't
like what corporations are doing then
you should change the incentive
structure
i will say i am amused to watch all of
these corporations who attempted to
comply with the dictat
of the woke left now being eaten by the
woke left so you may have noticed this
month because it is quote unquote pride
month
you may have noticed that every major
corporation that you can think of has
decided to change its logo
to include rainbows and then now they've
all they've all got rainbows right i've
got zillow on my phone
and zillow has changed its logo to
include rainbows wow so all the houses
are gay houses now or something
okay well congratulations and now people
who are who are cynical might say that
they are doing this because they wish to
appeal to the most radical base
and they feel that everybody on the
right is just going to ignore it which
is why nickelodeon is pushing
transgender propaganda its children okay
but
remember the left will eat these people
aoc tweeted out
this week's guilty pleasure watching
representative jayapal from millage high
paul go down the list to expose phony
corporate
pride rebrands with how much money
they've given to fund anti-lgbt plus
politicians remember
just because a company slapped on a
rainbow doesn't mean they support the
lgbt plus community
yes they're never going to stop gang you
decided to count out to them they're
never going to stop they're going to eat
you alive
and you know what you full well deserve
it you bought the ticket now you take
the ride
again you board you bore the risk and
now the risk is coming home to roost and
by the way folks on the right
we should get active in just the same
way it turns out we have market power as
well
and we are fully capable of using that
market power to change the incentive
structure for profit-seeking
corporations alrighty we'll be back here
a little bit later with an additional
hour of the ben shapiro show first you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show drew
shows every friday he's got an exciting
evening planned for you head on over to
dailywire.com this evening at 7 pm
eastern 6 pm central tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
bourne
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin